o malı bu çalışmada duygularına sesler
diyorum ben kendi duygularına sesler ve
ilişkide olduğum iletişim kurduğu
insanların gerçek duygularına e mahkum
diyorum duygular mesaj verir bu
dayanacak çölün Duydunuz mu Arkadaşlar
şöyle 1930 yılında başladığında artık
Çocuklardan bir tanesi aşağıda bazı
şekiller test etmiş bu şekiller Nazca
çizgileri olarak Anılır ve insanlığın
garip ve anlam veremiyorum veremediği
büyük ve devasa geometrik çizgiler acaba
niçin yapılmıştır erik
en kaliteli Tanrıların Arabaları adlı
kitabındaki fantastik anlatımına göre
uzaylıların gezegene ilişkileri için bir
ip miydi yoksa bundan 2800 yıl önce
yaşamış fazla uygarlığı için bu şekiller
yağmur duası için yapılmıştır yoksa
nasıl çalılar balonlarla uçak biliyorlar
ve aşağı görebiliyorlar mıydı ya da bir
çeşit takvim Gök Birlik çalışmaları
mıydı fazla ibadet için yapılmıştır gibi
gibi tamamıyla kesinleşmiş bir şey
söylemek mümkün değil insanoğlunun
toplumsal bir varlık olarak kullandığı
bir yazı resim ve sana kışın da
duygularıyla birbirlerine mesaj
veriyorlar bir sekilde ilişkilerin
sosyalleşiyor ve toplum toplumsal
ulaşıyorlar bu süreçte kendinize has bir
duygu bir repertuar
devam ediyoruz ne yapacaksın
çizgilerinin dediği mesajları okuyor
kendimizin ve Başkalarının duygu
haritasına gelişim kurmaya anlamaya
anlamlandırmaya düzenleyip dönüştürmeye
yönelik yeteneklerinizi alabiliriz
duygular bir iletişim Artık her şeyden
önce bir duygularla iletişim kurmaya
başladı kendimizle sosyal insanlarla
ilişkilerimizi dengede tutabilmek için
hissediyor insanoğlu için birileriyle
bağlantıda kalmak ve empatik anlayış
içinde olmak son derece yaşam kaldır
Portakalı bilirsiniz daha çok 18'ler
dünya yaygın arincik öyle türlerinden
birisidir orta okul otobüsü yakaladın
üzerinde portakal olarak alırız
yeminlerle uzun yolculuk yapan
mürettebatta bir hastalık görülüyor ve
bir en komik bir hastalığı D vitamini
Bu otobüs gördü ve portakal bir C
vitamini deposu olarak Bu hastalığı
önlediği ve durdurduğunu keşfeden
Kaptanlar uzaklık Yanıklar geçmeyi
başarmışlar Bundan 3 Yüzyıllardır Belki
annenin portakalla karşılaşma Alanya'dan
develerle köyleri derecat satıcılarda
görmüştük 66 ya da şimdi portakal ve
meşhur Antalya'nın Portakalı ünlü olsa
da annemin köyün defa o zamanlar bir
tanecik ve portakal ağacı yokmuş
portakalla ilgili unutamadığı bir değil
mi Ben burada portakalla ilgili
unutamadığım bir anımı paylaşıyorum
doğançam Köyü İlkokulu'na gönderildiği
ilk gün yapamamıştım geri dönüş Eve
Dönüş tüm Ben de 10 yaş küçük abi
okuldan kaçtığımız düşündüm bana
kızıyordu benim bağırarak çağırarak
ediyorduk üzerime geliyor
Bu okulda okula zorla gitmek için Beni
ikna etmeye çalışıyor ben ağlıyordum
ağlıyordum Amin demelidir ve baktı
olmayacak beni bırakıp gitti Bende
evinizin damına doğru merdivenlerden
burada gitmiş 3. basamağına oturmuş öyle
bekliyordum Yalnızdım kara kara
düşünüyordum bir yandan da ağlıyordum
öyle karşıdan okul öncesinde mahallede
oynadığım arkadaşlardan birinin bana
doğru geldiğini gördüm Hasan bana doğru
geliyor da elinde bir portakal vardır
unutuyordum burnuma gelmişti bana doğru
yaklaştık ve birkaç film kal uzakta kal
yavaşça uzandım Ağzıma bir tane bilim
attım Hasan o sırada bana söyle sordu
okuldan alil Neden ki
Sen okuyor musun dedi adam değil 7
yaşında olsa da beni altta yatan Duygu
mu empatiyle yakalanmıştı okuyordum
Çünkü okuldan benden büyükler vardı
hiçbirini tanımıyordum atan Şöyle devam
etti Hadi ya ben de korkuyorum ama dedi
gel ikimiz birlikte gidelim birbirimize
arkadaş oluruz Birbirimizi korur bir ona
Güvendi ilkokul arkadaşım Atanın yaptığı
neydi benimle abimin yapamadığı ile kişi
o bir şekilde kurmuştuk bir şekilde
kalbimi okumuştu empatik bir şekilde
altta yatan duygularıma Tamer kurmuştu
onu kalmamış bana bir yanıt vermişti
izler nasıl düşüreceğiz de bebeğin
lerimizden öğreniyoruz beni beyinleri
Kılıç geceler diyorum edilebilir bu
kadar doğumu gerçekleştiren ve
E tabii ki filmi izleyenlerin vardır
belki uzaydan dünyadan uzaya gitmiş Bir
psikolog grubu vardı onlardan bir tanesi
yalnız Kalmıştı bir türlü dünya ile
bağlantı kuramıyor astronot Right on
yapayalnız boşlukta Bir keresinde bir
köpek sesi duydu bu onu öyle mutlu etti
o anda Mutluluktan ağladı insan için bağ
kurmak ilişkide olmak duygularını
anlaşılması yaşam al son derece sevgili
arkadaşlar sağlığımızın Özünde bu vardı
zaten duygu ve uygulama süreçlerinde
yatak sağlığımız Duygu duyguların
sürecinde olanlara verdiğimiz Birsel
anlamlar etkilerdi yani bir şeyler
içinden geçer bir buna öfkelerin
üzüntülerini ve utanç derisi deri gibi
uygulanacak duygulanım psikolojik olarak
gittikleri bildirisi
Bu bir üzgün kenarları gözümüzde yaş
sökülür öfkeliyken yüzümüz kızarır bunun
gibi ideolojik belirtiler vardır
Karşınızdaki kişinin niyetiniz onun
duygularından anlarım duygularla karşı
tarafa da niyet gösterir duygular ifade
edildiğinde başkalarını etkileyebilir
İncil iletişim sistemlerimizi birincil
hanımlarımızın önce duygularımız bizim
kim olduğumuzu tanımlar bağlanma
orospulara kimlik üst üste Güler temelde
duygulanım süreçlerden geçerek oluşur ve
sakinlik olmadan bağlanma olmaz Korkmaz
sanıklara görmekten kaçamayız iyi
duymazsa katılım göstereyim öfkeleniriz
kıllarınızı koruyup sürdürebilir uygular
olmazsa birini aramayız bağ kurmayı
desteklediğiniz hissetmeliyiz alamayız
başarı elde edemeyiz bebeklikten
başlayıp yaşam boyu süren duygu ve duygu
duygulanım
bir insan ilişkilerini yöneten bir
pusula gibi bir yaşamın ilk yıllarında
bakıcılarının duygulanım larıyla tekrar
eder semahlarımız oluyor duygusal
yüzölçümüne göre varolmanın kendinize
çevrenize olmanın yollarını arıyor o
zaman gözlemlenen uygulanır gerçek Bu
yansıtmıyor anne babamızın yüzündeki
duygulara bakarak durum biraz bekliyoruz
algılarını çizgileri hakkında kurulan
teoriler video Bu yüzden her
ağladığımızda ya da hep Korktuğumuzda
öfkelenen bir yüz görmüş yetişkinlikte
korku ve üzüntü gördüğünüzde hemen ona
bahsettiğimiz de öfkeyle tepki verir Bu
yüzden duygularını kavrayamaz İskitler
istediğim diyemeyiz Uyumsuz duygusal
tepkiler hem iç çatışmalar ımıza hem de
dış çatışmalarını da bir şeyler al
abone ol aramıza neden olur uygular
işlem gösterir sosyal bağlarımızı Burada
neler oluyor Bir sorun mu var
ihtiyaçlarını karşılamıyor mu
karşılanmıyor mu Bunların hepsi de
uygular ayakta kalmamı iletişim kurmamız
problemlerini çözmemiz için bir motor
işlevi görür arkadaşlar duygusal ihmal
ve istismarı sonuçları bunlar bir ihmal
ve istismar dediğimizde fiziksel
istismar kadar duygusal travmaların
kaynağı ne kadar fiziksel istismarlar
olsada duygusal olarak duygusal olarak
yılmamış olarak yer mi
bu duygularımız yerinde ve zamanında
edilemez bir şekilde açıklanamaz empatik
bir şekilde karşılanmadığında empatiden
yoksun reddedildiğini Cezalandırıcı
ihmal K ve düzensiz bir çevrede
büyümenin sonuçlarını bir görelim
edilebilirsiniz kediler bir şekilde
kakalarını örtüyorlar bunu yapıyor bizim
de bunu da adlı kedimiz var evde ile
istiyorum deyip duruyor Hiç merak
ettiniz mi Bunu neden yapar ilerleyen
yırtıcıların onları ve yavrularını olay
bulmalarını istemiyorlar yok olmak
istemiyorlar yavruların dışkılarını
dileyerek istedikleri bilir kakao yarım
ilkokul şekerli kokuyla da izleyebilir
etmiş olurlar Biz insanlar da
uygulamamızı izlemeyi öğreniyor Çünkü
ilk yıllarında birçoğu yapacağımızı
bilemeyiz ettiğimiz duygular
Beklediğiniz istediğiniz gitti
çok az vereceğimiz uygulama ne
yapacağımızı nasıl başı değildi ve
bilemeyiz ve edeceğiz destekte
bulamazsak İşte o zaman sorunlar
başlıyor yani uyum sağlamaya hizmet eden
adli uygular hayatta kalmak yaşamını
sürdürmek için gerekli olan duygular
içinde istedik deneyin Dönmez'in
voleybol maçında top yaklaşır gibi
karşılıklı akım nedenle patlatılmaz
karşılanmazsa bir telefonu şarjı
koyduğumuz gibi içeride bir enerji
birikmeye başlar Akın bana yaptığı gibi
duygularını yansıtan bir bulunmamış da
Bunlar içinde birikmeye devam et abi
tekrar tekrar tekrar tekrar eden bir
şekilde birikmeye devam eder ve biriken
bu duygular bir şekilde boşalmak ister
e-şarj olmaktadır geçerli olmak bir
başka duyguyu kiralar yani o gizlenmiş
duygular bir başka duyguyla ifade
bulmaya çalışır Bu da bir kısır döngüdür
bu kısır döngüden
Evet hemen kolay olmuyor Hep öfkeliysen
öfkelendiğimiz ayrılmazsa takımda altta
yatan bir başka uygun edilebilir Bizler
ve asıl duygularımızı başlayan yoksa
kediler dediği gibi saklamak zorunda
kalıyor Yerine göre bütün duygular bir
buzdağının görünen bir gördüğünüz gibi
öfkenin altında utanç korku Kader
duygular vardır ayakla gibi duyguları
dışa vurumudur etrafında öfke genellikle
tipinin temel utanç ve güçsüzlük
duygularıyla Yani bir yerlerde bir
sürdük bir yerlerde utancını tetikleyen
bir yaşam olayla karşılaştığında hemen
öfkeyle etkilendim güçsüzlük duygularına
uğraşmakta yetersiz kalırım bu tür
öfkeler işlevsizdir kedinin kumardı
ışığını gizleme çabası gibi bir asıl
duyguyu asla bırakamayız otur derinlerde
yaşamaya devam eder arkadaşlar
ilişkilerimizde çak
Sen neden olur de psikolojik İyi olma
alimidir bir kutsal okuryazarlığın
alfabesi empati sevgili arkadaşlar
empati kazanabilir öğrenebilir sake bir
şekilde de karşınızdaki çalışmalı
ilişkilerinizde insanlarla sorunlarımızı
çözebiliriz bir şekilde büyük bir ihmal
ve istismara uğramış duyguları
anlaşılmamış duyguları yüzünden bir de
cezalandırılmış hatta kabul görmemiş
kişiler doğaları gereği hissettim bütün
duyguları Biraz önce sözünü ettiğim gibi
üyesi olarak ve bunlara bugün arka
çizgilerini anlam veremediğim gibi
karşısındaki kişilerle anlam verememe
dokunamaz ne zaman ki patik bir yaklaş
makamından aklından portakalla yaptığı
gibi empatik bir şekilde yaklaştığında
İşte o zaman çözülmeye başlar fiziksel
ve duygusal istismar bu tür yaşam
olaylarına maruz kalan insanların
ilişkilerinde yüz ifadeleri
ne olduklarını söyleyebiliriz
karşısındakinin karşındaki kişinin Yusuf
adetinde en küçük ani değişiklik onda
neden yüksek bir duygu patlaması Yaşasın
Bir taşın kalkması bir göz bebeğinin
küçülmesi ona tehlikedeyim ya da Hatip
var aldığı geliştirir Bu yüzden kişiler
arası ilişkilerde aşırı duyarlılık
gösterirler Minişler ve uzun verildiği
sürdüremezler başkalarının ötümlüleşme
karşı hak olurlar genellikle iletişimler
de yanlış anlarlar ve aşırı stresli
olurlar duygularını düzenlemekte de
yeter alırlar uygulanan anlaşılması ve
düzenlenmesi için neler yapılabilir
insanların Tabii öyle biyolojik olarak
da beyin gelişimi hakkında bakanlıkta
duyguların regülasyonu duyguların
dengelenmesi prefrontal korteksten
gerçekleşiyor bu doğumdan itibaren
ergenlik süresince yetişkinliğe kadar
devam
şu ana kadar devam ediyor çocukların
beyninde ki bu ön notlar Duygu
düzenlemeye karar vermeye sebep-sonuç
ilişkisi kurmaya ve eş sesli kontrolünün
geliştirmeye yarar ve bunlar çok İşte
tamamlanmamıştır bu süreçte bakım
verenlerin biletleri yazmak bu destek
erken çocuklukta göz kontağı ile oluşan
bağlanma ve duygusal uyumlanma deneyimi
bir şekilde yaşam boyu diğer
ilişkilerinde sürüp gider Tabi ki bu
içmeyiz elastik esnek bir her an değişme
potansiyeli vardır Kendini ve
başkalarının duygularını algılama
yeteneğini keşfetmesi böyle bir
yeteneğim var bu getirmeyi keşfetmek
için Sevgi duygularının farkında
duygularını ve düşüncelerini
yönlendirebilmek için duygularına Eriş
Melis'in ve duygularını ister etme
yeteneğini geliştirilmelidir öylece
duygusallık anında güçlendirebilirsiniz
duygularını
ama onlara gelişmeye onları anlamaya
düzenlemeye gerektiğinde dönüştürmeye
yönelik yeteneklerini artırmayı öyle
öğrenmeliyiz ya